speaking of superstitions so you said no
black cats because of superstition like
what our actual superstitions you really
believe in me yeah I believe in a lot
tell me you name a few I had on the bed
yeah you're a bad luck oh really I had
on the bed yeah no yeah you ever see the
movie Drugstore Cowboy with Matt Dillon
oh yes yes I remember that yeah they say
you had on the bed your bed look yeah oh
that makes a lot of sense no wonder I've
been music I don't believe it I believe
in that I believe in walking underneath
the arm ladder ladder walking underneath
the ladder is just it's just bad luck oh
bugger you're gonna open umbrella
indoors oh that one too
yeah oh another one that came true in
the Philippines hiding a person that's
one touching a person babe babe babe
remember remember not the Persian yeah I
don't want to touch a person yeah but
don't ever touch a person I've kissed
that's ten years older than that very
pretty
yeah but bad luck for thirty years
because a pretty girl yeah mm BRR
remember in the Philippines we right
before I had my whole like a medical
emergency where my heart basically legs
loaded like a ticking time bomb we went
out to a Chinese restaurant and we had a
whole fish like a whole steamed fish and
I told Bobby it's like you know it's
it's bad luck if you when you eat like
the top part of the fish and then you
flip it to eat the other side you're
supposed to eat the fish up to eat the
meat up top peel the bone off and then
eat the under part so you just remove
you're not supposed to flip the fish but
see the thing is that then literally we
did it anyway they're like ah [ __ ] it
[ __ ] the superstition and then five
hours later I was in an emergency room
and I was in intensive care
so that's one that I hang on to so I'll
never flip a [ __ ] fish again I know
it's stupid but well you know um can I
just say this though in some countries
they just completely think the bones
help if the day before they sort of
serve it to you why was what do you mean
why everything has to be fully for you
yes really that's world [ __ ]
oh can I let ask you this kalila yes if
I were to love steak and they brought
half
of a cow out which they did yesterday
when you order it has the tail right I
mean like this is [ __ ] I just want
the side have you not seen a Filipina
let John they'll put the whole [ __ ]
pig on a table with its face and
everything and you gotta flip it over
they're not gonna go there any uh Korean
superstitions that your parents kind of
followed what touch a person what no I
don't mean that I mean they they weren't
superstitions my dad would say stuff
like don't watch TV too close you know
grandpa will die he'll mix it up I like
the committee reversal yeah anyway like
you would make [ __ ] up yeah yeah man
wrap all will die yeah yeah I said he's
already dead when you say when you do
you know the you cross your eyes then
they say if the wind blows or if you're
laying on the floor and then someone
walks over you you're gonna your growth
is gonna get stunted and you'll never
grow past that height thing that's a
very like Philippine that's when my dad
does yeah yeah speaking of growing
though that one astronaut he grew 2
inches 2 inches George so Scott Kelly
who spent 340 days in space because of
microgravity up there he came back and
and they measured him and he was two
inches taller you you know this is gonna
happen that the Chinese are gonna go up
there and have a program where you know
because you know what they do now if
they want to get taller mm-hmm they some
Chinese people they had that surgery
where they cut the bone right then they
live a gap so the bone fills in it's the
most painful surgery were six years to
fill in but these young people do it so
they can get taller but you know that
they're gonna go to space now that's how
much they want to get tall is they
they'll cut the bone leave a gap and it
fills in
yeah but part of the reason why Asian
people weren't all to begin with was
because of like poor nutrition but if
you see the Koreans now like who
actually live in Seoul or like in the
more you know in bigger cities in Asia
they're tall yeah I know
like Korean girls I I mean even when I
was in Korea they were like five seven
five eight yeah who actually lived in
the city I'm not sure about the rest I
mean Filipinos are generally still short
yeah but I I mean we my sister my sister
six feet old I guess mm-hmm
but she's mixed with French so anyway uh
yes this Scott Kyle Kelly went up there
for a year and then everyone's
celebrating the fact that he was in a
spacecraft for a year and I'm like who
gives a [ __ ] why that's the most amazing
thing this guy know right now I don't
give a [ __ ] let me say this okay
Nikolai asked me kalila asked me can you
do it I could do that all day dog what
Joan space yeah for a year can I do okay
look for starters Scott Kelly I follow
him on Instagram and I follow him on
Twitter he he takes the most like
amazing photographs even like I could do
that too dude
he actually is a legit astronaut this
isn't his first time I'm just saying
that can Bobbili survive in space for a
year no all why I don't even think you
can handle the g-force of any like
upwards or downwards travel I think you
would like throw up and pass out that's
not true
yes I think we should what you you know
why because I was at a carnival once
right and they had this thing you know
that thing where it spins like in a room
and it spins in a circle and everyone
gets stuck to a wall right no yeah you
get stuck to the wall with a g-force and
there was a malfunction I sort of got on
this thing
where they couldn't turn it off so
everybody was on this thing I swear to
God for 40 minutes and it always
supposed to be on it for three to three
minute forty minutes yes pretty minutes
40 freaking hour yeah yeah they shut the
thing down right this isn't Del Mar they
shut it down right and I was stuck to
the side for 40 minutes and people who
are vomiting right it was coming into
their face right and I took a nap [ __ ]
nope no no business freak that asian guy
just sleeping right yeah it was no big
deal
I just like this I give a [ __ ] 40
minutes I wasn't panicking and I could
have done another nine hours yeah [ __ ]
g-force there you go
everyone got out and there was a ha
ambulance people were like coming on
Gurney's if people thought people are
gonna die right I walked out I wasn't
even dizzy
I walked out I had a cigarette was it
later
I left your [ __ ] bro Nate Diaz style bro
2:09 my scene spirit yeah so [ __ ] the
g-force give me nothing here's what else
will I survive I don't think that you
can I can float yeah I know you can
float but I mean like he Scott Kelly did
other things in the International Space
Station he's a legit astronaut I'll wipe
down the mirror hey Bob there's like a
little space debris on the wind mirror
wipe it down okay I think that we should
propose this to to NASA then I think
that you you should be you should give
your year a year of your life to science
yeah and you should try and beat Scott
Kelly's record of 340 how much one to do
that five years
give me five million dollars for five
years I'll do it for five years have you
do it for five years
well date number one will I get space
food up there yes you will number one
that's fine I wonder if your dick grows
Bobby will test that because that shirt
one year out of the five one you will be
dedicated for that dictator oh yeah I'll
stretch it out yeah man
give me an I'll masturbate you know me
what it's in space hey I'm not and then
I'll swallow the come floating in there
I'll do all that I'm just saying that I
could do it for a year now if they're
like hey can you fix that engine or jet
propulsion I would be like I don't know
anything about that so that's how Scott
Kelly has an advantage over me but in
terms of just like living up there it's
not a big deal
it's all I'm saying anyone can do that
George can do it you can do it everyone
can do it I would have a panic attack in
the first two days to be confined like
that to not have just I would freak the
[ __ ] out I even thinking about it my
anxiety is through the roof there's no
cameras where I can do things you know I
mean I wonder if you can smoke up there
or you can actually just show you that
no you would have to just have probably
nicotine patch or like a chew right why
can't you smoke up there because
I mean unless you vape up there I'm sure
you can babe you vape yeah I don't know
too much about that
I wonder what sex is like we always been
like in that when you're floating like
that it's like being on a I don't know
what would be like it would just be
really slow it would just
yeah it's lost oh yeah you would really
have to have controlled movements porno
Becca
[Music]